okay so
last class we started talking about
virtue ethics again
and we explored this question of
happiness
we talked about a lot of different goods
right what makes happiness for you
or other people we looked at aristotle's
idea we even looked at a few flawed
conceptions
of happiness like you know the people
who think that it's just
wealth or just health or you know just
these things
and we mentioned this term virtue
and i said that we'd be exploring this
in a lot greater detail today is where
we start that
we're still working in fairly general
terms today we're not going to get to
look at the virtues one by one like
we're going to do
over the next couple weeks
when we go to book three four and five
in book two
he's concerned with a more general
question he's going to use specific
examples but he's concerned this more
general question
what is and we've used this
term quite a bit over the course of the
semester right
and we've had a few definitions of it
and sometimes people focus in
on these as if they're the definition of
virtue
and a good definition should include
everything that goes into it
so let's take for example just before we
actually go into this
one definition that that
some people have used of virtue that i'm
starting to see
show up in papers and journal entries
socially approved character traits
that's true virtues are in general
socially approved character traits
does that tell you everything that
virtue includes
does that tell you an awful lot about it
um
i mean the fact that it's socially
approved
does that tell you why it's socially
improved well let's think for example
about something that we tend to approve
of
honestly right
why is honesty good
yeah i guess it would be for
like the opposite because you're not
lying i guess
because you're well it's the definition
but you're not
you're telling the truth you know it's
better to be
yeah truthful than not so yeah that's
what we
see and sometimes we can define things
by
negating our opposite don't be a liar
you know that's like saying be honest
right
what are you gonna say basically like
if that's how you want to be treated
that's the energy that you want to put
into the world
if you practice honestly you'll get
honest with that yeah there's something
to that too
oh well as a factual statement
you can be honest and other people might
screw you over right
but you're on to something really really
important by saying how would you like
to be treated
and and you there's a sort of
reciprocity there right you look at
how you would like other people to
behave towards you and then you can say
well i should probably act that way too
if i want them to do that
now we're starting to get further away
from just social approval though aren't
we
i mean you can say well you know a given
society thinks that it's important to be
honest
why well because you know that helps out
interpersonal relations or if we lie
then there's certain consequences that
have followed
or there's something just intrinsically
wrong with wine
you
we can do we can go through a process
like this for anything that we want to
consider to be a virtue
and you can think about this also with
vices if we say vices are
in general socially disapproved of
character traits
like being a coward for example almost
every culture
doesn't like congress that's that's
pretty universal
um well what is it about cowards that's
a problem
you know that's something to think about
and when we ask this question what is
virtue
and relatively what is vice we're
getting into that why we're not just
asking
what question we're actually asking
questions
my my question was so basically
i may have misunderstood so under virtue
ethics honesty
so you're not honest just for the sake
of being honest or you're honest
because of the consequences that you
yeah it's a little bit more complex
right it's it's not
just the consequences the way it would
be for say utilitarianism
right but the consequences do have some
weight in it
let me let me go on with this and maybe
that'll become a bit more
clear so aristotle actually gives you
a few definitions of virtue at different
points in this and this is
one of the the definitions that he gives
you
in booktube and you notice it has four
main parts to it
and none of these have to do with
socially approved character traits
that's in some way
it's an important part but it's also
kind of accidental why are these
socially approved
because they deep down inside
have this and aristotle doesn't think
that anybody like reasons this out says
what should we approve of in society
well let's look at this and
you know start looking for examples
instead he thinks that
we end up doing this sort of
more or less unconscious level in
societies
but then we can bring theory to bear and
make some more sense on this but that's
what we're trying to do
so we're going to look at each one of
these today
i just want to give you the general
overview a virtue is going to be a
settled or established disposition or
habit
so when we talk about character trait
okay a character trait
what makes it a character trait it's
something that a person tends to do over
and over again right
that could be a habit um
if it's a trait that you have it's not
just something that you do once in a
while
it's something that is specific to you
that somebody can say that person is
that way
is every character trait necessarily a
habit
not necessarily i mean some could be due
to
certain parts of your your body
you know maybe you have a maybe you have
a habit of chewing your fingernails we
don't tend to frown on that sort of
thing but maybe you also have some
something wrong in your brain that makes
you chew your fingernails
that could be a character trait but that
wouldn't be a habit
per se that would be something you don't
have so much control over
because aristotle thinks we do actually
have control over our habits
you're at the age right now where you
actually
have the greatest opportunity to
determine
what kind of person you're going to be
because you're starting to
you're almost fully developed as far as
your brain goes
i don't know if you guys have followed
any of these these things but
when it comes to impulse control those
of you who are in your early 20s
you're not fully there as far as your
brain development
your brain is still developing but
you're you're way further along than you
were when you were 18.
do you feel like you have more control
over your impulses now than three years
ago
i hope so you think you have more
control when you're 18 than you did when
you were say
14 yeah the reason why
middle schoolers by the way are such a
pain to teach
is because they have almost no impulse
control development and there's they're
getting smarter and smarter
so they they've figured out all these
ways to get into things
and they're unable to keep themselves
from getting into things but you guys
can do that now
and you guys are at the age where you
have the unique opportunity to look at
yourselves
and say what kind of person do i want to
be five years from now 10 years from now
and to lay down new habits by the time
you get to my age it gets more difficult
it's not impossible when you're 40. but
it's harder
than when you're 60 it's pretty well
established
most people don't change their
personality much when they're in their
60s
if you're hating you're probably not
going to change at all right
unless you have some epiphany and some
drastic
religious experience i guess it's
probably not going to happen
choice this is another thing that's
really important
and we're going to look at this choice
consistent for arizona more
uh next class session
aristotle thinks that our character
traits are
in some respect product of our choices
does it mean that you're perfectly
responsible at every moment for every
single thing that you do know
but you are a product of the choices
that you've made so far
and who you're going to be five years
from now is a product of the choices
that you're going to be making over the
next
you know year month who knows
you have some control over what kind of
person you're going to be
and what are the choices there on uh
actions
this makes perfect sense right because
we've talked about actions a lot in
ethics
but what else emotions doesn't that seem
like a
strange thing to say choice is bearing
on emotions
i mean you do you choose to be angry
when you're angry
do you choose to be sad you ever had
somebody
say to you step out being sad is just a
bad choice on your part
when you know you're grieving about
something
how's that come across to you yeah
i think um our emotions are like
determined by our
because you can say actions sometimes do
something wrong and then you feel bad
about it you know but it's just gonna be
wrong
that's true if you don't want to feel
bad about things don't do things that
make you feel bad
and you can control what sort of
situations you get into if you know that
you have a tendency
to get angry um
let's say let's say you're the kind of
person who gets angry when talking about
sports
you get really into it you know that you
you
you lose your temper when talking about
people who don't see things the way that
you do
well you could avoid those kind of
situations once you're actually in the
situation
it's you don't have a lot of control
over whether you feel angered
but one second you do have control over
what you do with it don't you
how far you go how you act on
your emotion yeah but that now that's
what i was gonna throw out there
and you just did so
we have control over right so because if
you're angry
you can either like indulge your anger
like light the flame even more
or try and reserve yourself and hold
yourself back you could still be angry
but not necessarily
explode with anger you know what i mean
yeah and you know the better that you
get to know yourself
the more control you end up having
over what to do with your emotions so
like one of the very first things that
they they teach you and a lot of anger
management books
is to tell yourself as soon as you get
angry somebody stupid is in charge at
this point
and that sounds really silly one second
that sounds really silly doesn't it
but actually it is helpful they also
teach
you little things like when you get
angry
take 10 deep breaths this somatic stuff
and you might say that's that's just
crazy stuff you're still going to be
angry
well taking the time actually helps you
to cool down a little bit to gain a
little perspective it's not a sure-fire
thing
but you can learn these techniques and
you can also learn
your own makeup so that you can make
better choices about emotions
when you're saying that we can't control
like the feeling of anger but we can
kind of control how we show it is that
kind of what you're getting at
sort of although aristotle will say that
we we don't have
a direct control once we actually start
feeling it
we do have a control over how we shape
our ourselves and our perceptions
um over time
and that will affect how we feel to you
know how much we feel it when we feel it
because
there's a kid that i live with who when
you when you brought up
gets angry over sports is it's the first
person and he's always over my house so
he brought it up
yeah but um and he has like a social
disorder so
he gets very angry over the knicks games
and we talk to him every time he yells
and i just feel like it's it's bad she's
she's our age
like i live next door and i live
upstairs and he loves downstairs
i was thinking maybe that there's some
circumstances where
you can't quite control the emotions
yeah that brings up a good a good point
we're going to get into this again
more again in book three and in book
seven
i mentioned this last class that there
is there's quite a few things
i think it was in response to a question
that there are some things that we
consider to be
psychological disorders which aristotle
would see as perhaps having some
psychological element but that actually
be moral
issues so that in our culture
we've tended to push the moral off to
one side and make everything into
psychological things that we can
diagnose and then say the person's not
responsible
aristotle would sort of push back he
wouldn't go all the way and say
you're responsible for every single
thing there's no such thing as a person
who's got a
psychological disorder that keeps them
from from making the right choices
he would recognize that in certain cases
but he would say that there's
there's a lot of cases where it's more
moral than psychological and there's a
lot where they sort of interact with
each other
and i suspect that the case that you're
talking about would be like that
although you know aristotle cautions us
don't make
general you know absolute declarations
about individual cases until you look at
the
the the facts and can you draw on some
experience
which is i think a good idea let's go on
a little bit with this
observing the mean relative to us that's
another important
characteristic and this is a distinctive
contribution that aristotle makes
with plato you don't have a
concept of a mean with the virtue being
in between two extremes you have the
virtue
and then you have advice like justice
and injustice courage
cowardice um temperance intemperance
right moderation in moderation i guess
you would say
lack of moderation um wisdom
and foolishness with aristotle
the virtue is actually going to be
located in the middle position between
the two extremes
so that's something new and we're going
to talk about that a bit more
then determined by reason as the prudent
person or the virtuous person
virtuous you gotta put it under them
yeah
there's something missing okay um
thanks so determined by reason that
sounds like plato doesn't it
reason is the capacity that tells us
what we ought to do you know wisdom
is you know the virtue of that capacity
reason should be governing the appetites
it should be governing our sense of
honor or anger things like that but
plato doesn't talk so much about
examples for aristotle
examples are really important
aristotle thinks that we learn what it
is to be virtuous
which is good and unfortunately also
what it is to be vicious
by observing and then imitating other
people
so the good news is if you've got some
good people in your life
without even necessarily thinking about
it you might have imitated them and
become
virtuous in certain respects bad news
is just you know the exact opposite
if you've got some bad people in your
life um
you may have started to imitate them
take on their characteristics and become
vicious
as as a result and entire societies can
in some way be virtuous
and vicious you know our society has
certain things that it doesn't really
want to talk much about
but arizona would and the things that
our society
doesn't want to see as vices that
aristotle would maybe
other societies would see those as vices
but they'd have their own problems
so we're going to look at each one of
these in turn but first i want to talk
about
something else that he brings up he uses
this word nature a lot
and i want to make really clear his idea
of nature
is kind of complicated it's not
something
just like what you have in biology class
or or
physics class or something like that
let's take for example when you talk
about the nature of things
this is a piece of chalk it has a
certain nature right
anybody in here a science major i know
there's
um some sort of calcium compound but i
don't remember exactly what it is
anybody
i think they make this from limestone
that sound about right
okay so we know certain things about
this and it's a physical object if i
drop it it's going to fall
right as aristotle says you can take a
stone and throw it up in the air as many
times as you want
you're not going to train it to stay up
there it's going to keep doing the same
thing
this has a very fixed nature
so does uh this this is a different
nature it's the
thing i wipe my glasses with because
nowadays apparently i can't wipe your
glasses on just anything it's got to be
this special kind of cloth
otherwise you know coating they put on
it gets screwed up
right so it's got a certain nature it's
good for something wiping my glasses
you wouldn't use it for other things
like blowing your nose or
wiping the board or anything like that
because it's got this purpose
those are very simple things that are
probably like 10 bucks each
probably i only yeah i have no idea i
get them when i get my new glasses
every two years or so and then i try
like how not to lose them
uh i'm used to like wiping glasses on
shirts
this is actually a source of great
irritation for me
the fact that i have done this special
thing to wipe my glasses
which is probably a sign of not virtuous
with respect to anger yet
um okay so now think about
more complicated things now we get into
the world of living things
what about plants you plant a seed
you remember back in your elementary
school you did some experiment with
planting seeds
what happens if you if you water it if
you actually put it in the right place
the seed splits open a little sprout
comes up
maybe you took it home maybe it was a
watermelon plant because that's one of
the easiest things to grow
and put it in the backyard and you
either grew and
made watermelons or die or maybe pumpkin
pumpkins are also
one that they do for kids too right
beans that would work too yeah
beans are good because they're nice and
big so you can observe it too
now we don't talk about plants as being
capable of anything moral
can you do an awful lot with a plant you
change its its habits
its nature can you bring out certain
things of it
yeah over time you know with
breeding think about corn for example
you know we have all this
corn that we use for making all sorts of
products
even gasoline ethanol and here's a
corner about this lawn
did they start out like that
no right uh at the time that that cortez
and the conquistadors were coming into
mexico which which was
corn was a staple crop along with beans
and squash
corn is about that big like there's a
little baby corn that you see in the
what we call chinese food here right
and they grew it and then they bred it
to be bigger and bigger and bigger
but not not this big that would really
be something
maybe they'll maybe they'll be this big
you know when you guys are here
because they keep getting bigger even
this amount was was a big advance
because corn was a grass and it was
domesticated and we took it and we
slowly brought out things that were
there in its nature
but weren't there to begin with we
cultivated it
and it's that way with every other plant
that we've cultivated
and you know you can do this with other
plants not necessarily food plants
you can train them to move certain ways
you can take trees and
you bend them and they'll stay bent
but there's not an awful lot of
development going on there what about
animals
how many of you have dogs or kids just
pets
some good good proportion how many of
you have dogs or cats
probably some of you living in the dorms
you know you had them at one time right
can you change the nature of a dog or
cat in any sort of
absolute way can you make a cat
bark can you
can you take a dog and make it not
interested in other animals
maybe but you'd have to really really
change that dog
there are people who like you know their
dogs to be vegetarians and things like
that but
you have to do incredibly complex things
whereas the dog gets
gets you know vitamin deficiencies and
gets kind of sick
if you don't do it just right
yeah that's like my brother has an
australian sheepdog
and the dogs they call it a bipolar dog
my mom and i
because it's just so hyperactive and his
girlfriend has been trying to train it
to like not be hyperactive but you can't
change that that's all
that's that's tough to do yeah and it's
probably that way in part because
a lot of the dogs that we have as
domesticated breeds were bred to do
something
and if the dog isn't actually doing
something like that
the dog is going to be unhappy yeah like
she'll go up next to you and try to push
like against your leg what are you doing
and then you realize she's hurting
that's what she does yeah i remember
seeing a
sheep herding dog once herding kittens
there was this litter of kittens and
this dog
a friend of mine had it
it wouldn't let the kids the kids just
wanted to wander off you know
just what kittens do because they're
curious they're following instincts as
well
and this dog would keep them all within
like a small circle
she does that with the pool like if the
kids
what we did with breeding these dogs is
we took something
that was there in the dog's nature as a
potential
and then we bred it to become something
more and more actual
and and in some respects some of these
breeds are are prisoners
of their instincts that way you know
dalmatians are a great example too
there was a lot of problems with
dalmatians about
20 years ago with inviting kids and the
reason why that was happening is
everybody had seen you know 101
dalmatians and they're really cute
so they'd get a dalmatian puppy what
they didn't realize
is dalmatians are war dogs they were
bred by the dalmatians who
live that was the name of a particularly
war-like and
pirate-infested band of people living
in the adriatic um
near what's now called the city of
trieste
and they were independent for most of
their existence
they gave the romans a hard time they
gave everybody a hard time
until they were finally subjugated and
made part of italy
and they bred these dogs these beautiful
black and white you know spotted dogs
to go run alongside the fighting bed and
tear the throats out of people
and they were they were bred to be very
loyal to bond with their owners
and to protect them that's why they're
so good for firefighters
not so good for kids you know it's sort
of like leaving a loaded gun around
right
um they have they have very strong
incidents that way
could you you know raise them in such a
way so that
it's very unlikely that they'll bite
yeah but you'd have to do a lot more
work with them than with some other
ingredients
now can you take any dog as a puppy and
turn it into a bad dog
how what would you do do you abuse it in
the galactic department
yeah are neglectful
for one thing don't don't don't treat it
uh well i bet
i bet it depends on the dog because i
guess the dog
depends on his personality can either
like
go back into itself and kind of just be
scared of everything i've seen
like that or it can just work it's right
back it depends on the personality of
the dog
yeah you can take a dog i mean dogs are
fighting
animals they're like us they have their
eyes in front that means that we eat
meat
you know we can be vegetarians but we're
biologically
predatory creatures we're actually the
most successful producer
and dogs are a particularly successful
predator too
and you can encourage those bad traits
we can turn them into killing machines
if you want to
and that would be taking their nature
and bringing out certain parts of it and
then dampening the rest because dogs can
also be incredibly
affectionate loyal that's part of why we
like them isn't it
um you know cats we can do a little bit
less with them
i think than we can with dogs they get
more independent
but you can you can bring out certain
things in them and you can also screw
them up pretty badly too can't you
human beings are like this too and
like aristotle says we're not naturally
good and we're not naturally bad we have
capacities for goodness or compactness
but they have to be developed and they
will be developed in one way or another
depending on you know the choices that a
person makes the environment that they
find themselves in
the models that they take um so it's not
a completely neutral thing by the time
that you're
your age you've already made a lot of
choices and you're the product of those
those choices
by the time you're my age you actually
see a lot of the effects of that
and what we're doing when we think about
virtue's devices
we're cultivating certain things that we
have as capacities by nature
but we're making them take on a certain
shape
either for good or for bad and this is a
good place to take
up this notion of the piano aristotle
asks
how should we understand a virtue of a
character trait
one way to think of this is in terms of
a capacity
and i'm going to use anger as an example
here because it's a very clear
example all of us have a capacity to
don't we then have you not have the
capacity to get angry
so he starts poking you doesn't say why
just keeps poking you would you
eventually get ticked off with them
some of you probably wouldn't even be
eventually like me and take like
three or four pokes and i'd want to know
what the hell is going on and i you know
started getting irritated with the
person right um
even if they gave me a rational
explanation i might still be irritated
i'm doing an experiment
why are you doing it on me why are you
doing this right now
you know we have a capacity for getting
angry
would you be a better person if you
didn't have any capacity for being angry
stoics thought so
what do you think
would you be virtuous if you
were you know let's say you had all your
other emotions
but you didn't have this one
yeah i feel like you need to be ready to
get angry when you have to
but it shouldn't that you need to decide
what it's morally appropriate
yeah i think aristotle would see things
the way that you do that
there are times when we ought to get
angry i mean
it's in our nature for for a reason
what does anger help us to do that
sometimes we need to do
yeah defend ourselves you're right
at a bodily level the anger response
it's what we do to prepare ourselves for
fighting
that's why we sometimes fight with
marine follow through
yeah i was gonna say like uh i thought
about it it's probably not
not not right but like if somebody like
commits like a
heinous crime we get like angry with
them and like
like like presenting justice and stuff
and like putting on a white but that
would probably be under something
different right well it's interesting
because aristotle
actually thinks that if it's
you might say if it's structured if it's
set up the right way if anger is not you
know going beyond
bounds that it should not exceed
that anger can actually our feeling of
anger
can actually be a good index for
figuring out
how much a person should be punished
anger is actually a desire to punish
other people in part to respond to
threats
and so aristotle himself
would be very sympathetic to the notion
that
anger in a certain way could be could be
legitimate
when it comes to sentencing people so
the judge
who's actually angry at the person that
he's sentencing and gives him a longer
sentence
because of the crime that he committed
and the circumstances
in which it was committed might be doing
the right thing from aristotle's point
of view
it's not a point of view that's widely
held no because
of the fact that like determinants have
to sing and stuff like that and
you think a person should be calm with
their senses yeah yeah and like giving
them
what you would give everybody for that
yeah and that does have to do with
the need to be just um aristotle then
says well
could it be could virtue be the emotion
itself
and you know we have all sorts of
emotions
you have an emotion of anger we've all
felt that
we have sadness happiness surprise
curiosity
admiration pity envy
there's an emotion that he's got a greek
word for that we often
use the german word shot and freud which
means taking joy in somebody else's
pain or damage or something like that
aristotle's term literally means setting
your hand to badness
you know turning your your hand to doing
something bad with
malice is the word that's an emotion too
sympathy friendship
these have to do with emotions it's not
the emotion itself though right
as you were pointing out yeah it's
almost like
the channel
yeah i think that's when mark said
if you saw someone doing something you
can get angry and go in and fight them
yourself or you get angry and call the
cops
and that's like almost finding the most
productive way to channel your emotions
yeah
um that's a very versatility way to look
at it
how you don't have control usually over
whether you feel the emotion
itself you do have an awful lot of
control over what you do with them you
know
i mean if you have the belief that every
time you get angry
you have to hit somebody very early on
in your life you'll have somebody who
takes you aside and you know makes that
distinction for you and says
you don't always have to act on your
anger you know it's not right to do that
it's okay to tell somebody you're angry
but not okay to throw a block at them
you know or something along those lines
and it's very hard to to stick to this
this is why habit becomes so important
how do you manage to
do the right thing with what you feel
or what you desire or what you want to
do
i mean there's knowledge and aristotle's
gonna say you know
being angry with the right person for
the right amount of time
for the right reason
those sorts of things those are in part
products of knowledge you know you could
say
you shouldn't be angry at somebody just
because they took something away from
you that you like
because maybe you didn't have a right to
have that thing you can tell somebody
that
is that enough to work to give them a
virtuous disposition to the does
everybody just say
now i get it i'm going to quit being a
bad person
i'm going to do the right thing we have
to have habits
we have to establish you talked about
channeling think of what take what it
takes to establish a channel you have to
dig a group
and have it digs grooves into our
personality and our action
by repetition by facing situations in
which we have to
act on these or you know other other
things as well
and we have to choose certain
responses you might say forces of action
and if we do that over over time
eventually we could acquire that he had
it you know say the virtuous cabinet
in this case
when aristotle has good temper
or we could develop bad habits and
become
irratible that's kind of a funny
word to throw out there somebody who's
just hot tempered who loses control too
easily
there's a lot of ways to go a wrong
thing or we'll look at this more
specifically later on
how do you develop this well you face
situations
in which it calls for a certain response
so let's go away from anger now
and let's think about fear
all of you have faced situations of fear
right probably still
um let's think about some common
situations
that come up think about two in
particular
childhood ones so you faced a bully
every one of you has probably had
somebody who messed with you at one time
earlier right
probably a lot of people because what do
kids do with each other when adults
aren't supervising
start screwing with each other you know
kids will play together nice for a while
but inevitably even kids who are friends
with each other will start picking at
each other won't they
that's that's the way we are again maybe
that has to do with their being
predatorial
and so what do you do when somebody
starts picking at you
one thing you feel probably is anger but
you also feel
a sense of fear quite often
what do you do in the face of that fear
do you give in do you say i'll give you
whatever you want just leave me alone
if you do that often enough what's going
to happen
not only socially outside of you what's
going to happen within you
you'll start to back down within
yourself yeah
you'll all you'll like approach each
situation like that
and the fear will be greater and greater
yeah it's weird that you bring that up
we had a kid
yesterday back at the high school that i
used to go to
now that i'm in college who committed
suicide yesterday
because he was bullied and you kind of
feel alone because you don't think that
anyone
kind of has your back yeah one of the
things that they express
often is you know despair about it ever
getting better
but fear about they say i i don't want
to go to school i don't i don't want to
even get out get out of bed
because of what's going to happen um
it may be that that for some in order to
cultivate some virtues we need
the assistance of others it's difficult
to stand up to
to believe when you are totally isolated
what happens if you stand up to the
bully i mean you might get get popped in
the nose
right that's no fun but what happens
is it easier to stand up to them the
next time
or mean kids picking up or whatever you
know yeah
it becomes easier think of another
example that's probably a bit
closer in time how many of you
right now still feel a sense of fear
when you have to give a talk
a presentation some sort of public
address
about okay so about a third of the class
um how many of you felt that originally
when you first started giving
presentations
almost everybody yeah i mean there are
some people who don't my mom
you know she liked uh playing teacher
all the time she was you know
kind through a life of the party kind of
person she she didn't
she didn't ever really seem to be afraid
of that sort of thing even when she was
a kid
i know it scared me especially when i
first started teaching
i would actually get up and i would keep
my hands behind the podium because
they would shake you know because i was
so nervous
uh i imagine my first you know few years
of teaching were probably
terrible for my students you know as far
as i'd over prepare because i was you
know
worried about it and then after a while
you get used to it don't you those of
you who had
been forced to do public speaking had to
take a speech class or something like
that
did you find yourself eventually
overcoming that fear
even though those of you who feel the
fear are you able to function when
you're called upon
are you able to get yourself out there
to do it
yeah me and actually actually had this
teacher
for american national government who i
think she's a philosophy teacher here
but she was like very nervous when
teaching and i think it was because she
never
had taught that class yeah but like she
had
been a teacher for a while you know what
i mean so like
so smart but everyone was uh
like and it was very difficult to listen
to her because
yeah she wasn't getting her point across
without saying
um yeah
it was so hard to power yeah i i there's
something to that i mean if i when i
have to give up
get get up and give like a really big
lecture in front of a ton of people
then i start to get a bit more nervous
again like i gave
i gave this uh samianself lecture at st
anselm college back in 2008
and by then i had been teaching for
eight years and i've done a lot i've
done i've done probably
30 conference presentations but this is
a big thing this is like an invited
lecture
i was the whole show you know and
i remember being at that podium that
that podium was a lot higher it was like
this high
and i had i had to talk for 45 minutes
and i had you know this whole long
prepared thing
um and i remember being really nervous
that i'd like start
stumbling over the words and maybe
stuttering or who knows
and then i thought i had the feeling
like boy if i if i go off the tracks
i'll never be able to get back
and i got myself through it but i was
feeling
anxious the whole time
there's actually a podcast on it so if
you want to hear it you can listen to it
and see whether you think
i'm engaging in any of those sort of
things and then
it turned to the question and answer
period and suddenly something kind of
like clicked and i was okay
and then i was actually kind of smart
ass getting some of the answers
if you listen to the podcast yeah um
jerry fox seinfeld makes a joke that
more people
think of studying more people are afraid
of speaking in public than they are
that you'd rather like rather be in the
casket than the person giving the eulogy
that's interesting yeah and
i actually have some experience with
giving eulogies and i can tell you that
that gets easier over time too they come
from a big family
i got asked to give a lot of eulogies
because there's always a lot of deaths
i mean i feel like no matter how many
speeches you give you're still going to
get those
first moment jitters i don't know that's
the way i feel like i have given like a
ton of presentations i work with people
like
i i don't get them you know in my office
but like when i'm giving large
presentations
yeah you get those first like 30 seconds
to a minute and then after that
like just drops a lot
i don't know perhaps in sports too i've
been playing football my whole life and
even my senior year in high school i
would still get nervous before games
yeah yeah i remember i did track and i
always get nervous
you get into the blocks you'd always get
nervous before you got to
before the the pistol would go up and
the thing i get the most nervous about
is
what if i don't like what if i hear it i
don't respond the way i'm supposed to
you know and like take off immediately
what if i do a false start
it's like the beginning to it it's like
like with themes like
you get out there and then the whole
crowd is watching you and then speeches
you
get up and the whole class is watching
you it's like the beginning it's just
it puts so many different like thoughts
into your mind and stuff like that it
just
messes with your head yeah now aristotle
would say to go back to this
how do you end up getting better and
better at this you put yourself in
situations where
courage is called for and courage itself
is not the opposite of fear encourages
what you do with that fear
courage is also what you do with the
feeling of confidence because you can go
this is a good segue into this you can
go to another stream as well
think about the story of goldilocks and
the three bears if you had to sum that
up
in three quick statements what would you
say
not even not even sentences but
statements
what is the story based around
i get to start two
teal
okay we'll start with that too cold
too hot just right yeah and if you
wanted to make it more general
too much too little just right well it's
the same way with virtues and vices
according to aristotle
you have vices at the end of excess
too much
you have vices at the end of deficiency
too little and then you have
that hard to reach and sometimes
hard to actually define well just right
um i think about orange for an example
you know
we don't even actually pour any oatmeal
or you know
things along those lines
what makes it just right
or forget forget how much sugar should
you put
some people might put it way too much
you know
some people don't even seem to realize
hey you can put sugar in
you're an adult you wanna eat sweeter
things you know you don't have somebody
telling you you can't
yeah i mean it's like an individual
preference for everybody
yeah when it comes to matters of taste
like that
there is there's a wide range of
subjectivity
we would actually look at somebody kind
of strange who puts more sugar than
a porridge
maybe you should eat something different
and we can do this with a lot of
different things in life
if we want to use anger as an example
and this will be the last time that i
use it in this class you can get
angry with a person to the right amount
and this is a difficult thing to pin
down but there are examples that we can
look at there are some sort of
fairly general rules right if you get so
angry at somebody
over um bumping you in a line that you
have to hit them
clearly you're on the side of excess
right
what sort of thing might be an
appropriate response
somebody blessing somebody's really rude
and bumps you in line
as they're moving past you
what would you consider an appropriate
response because you're sucking it up
and saying oh
sure they didn't mean it that might be
too little
what do you think um
like uh give them a look something
you know yeah yeah i'll definitely get
the message across that and you just
bumped into me don't do it again kind of
deal
yeah come and watch where they're going
yeah
that would probably be fairly
appropriate that'd be a lot better than
just like
going into like a five minute you know
string of profanity wouldn't it
you'd be shocked how people respond
well you know that's because this is
another good segway too
aristotle thinks that with some
matters some some things that virtue
advice is concerned with
societies and and people in general
can be too often on one side or too
often on
the other side and probably with
anger as human beings we tend to
make the mistake of going too far with
it
getting aimed at too many people too
long those sorts of things
rather than not getting angry enough and
then there are people who don't get
angry
when they often get angry but they're
more rare than people who get more angry
actually
what do you think in your experience
people more often get angrier than they
should or less angry than they should
yeah that was pretty pretty simple and
you know there are some people sort of
choke back their anger
and then they act in passive aggressive
ways aristotle actually
puts that on the side of the too much
because it's still
anger and it's held on to until they can
find some way to
to address it think about other things
too
what about justice and injustice there's
there's justice
you know in the sense of fairness giving
people what what's fair
taking only your fair share and then
there'd be like taking too much for
yourself and then they'd be taking too
little for yourself
which side do people tend to if they
make a mistake which side do they follow
usually too much yeah
in our society at least there might be
some in which
everybody is bending over backwards to
make sure that they don't take you know
their fair sharing everybody else gets
more than them
but that's pretty rare isn't it yeah i
was going to say with the
example that we had earlier with uh
sentencing somebody
you could either be very angry at them
and sentence them
twice as long as they should or kind of
let them off really easy due to some
like other reasons or give or like
determine sentencing where
no matter no matter what your background
is or anything like that like if you
commit a rivalry you get
this much this many years you know when
we get to justice
we're going to look at book five we'll
see what aristotle says
he would actually he would he would
um not be a big fan of determination
in part because it doesn't allow enough
latitude to the
to the judge to look at the
circumstances and the moral character
but he would still put too much too
little into it
oh yeah yeah you you can you can
definitely think about it in terms
and you have to compare it to other
people too so similar cases should be
treated similarly
but with some sort of uh
discretion yes exactly
the word that he uses the words that
aristotelians typically use
is equity but you're right in modern-day
criminal justice it would be what we
call
discretion yeah i mean the whole idea is
to
why limits are placed to judges to a
particular
uh sentence was because of abuse
of power yeah so you can fall on either
side
right so for us to allow
a judge to not have any limits would
make us to believe that he's a true
virtue
most likely a judge around here would
not be
so i mean a judge would send somebody
different that
committed a crime in his hometown versus
someone who did it in another town
he would feel more anger towards that
potentially because he
feels more closely related to it so
the idea is that like anger yes should
play a part as a judge you should feel
the anger
for society yes but yeah but however you
should be the more rational one out of
everybody in
making your decision yeah
um aristotle's not saying that the judge
should be angry all the time
right what we're talking about with
discretion is
relating a different different topic
you could exercise discretion
being angry or being calm okay so
there could be other emotions that could
come in too like you know the
sympathy for somebody from your hometown
for example
let's go back to this let's think about
one other one what about um cowardice
and courage is there something that goes
beyond courage that goes too far
sure aristotle calls it rashness or
foolhardiness
this is the person who who you know sees
conflicts everywhere
and responds to threats that aren't
actually there and
feels either not enough courage at all
or too much confidence
in these sort of situations so they jump
in and they get in all these these
fights with people
you know people like that that's not
necessarily fistfights
but you know people like that who like
to argue all the time
who seem to seek out opportunities for
getting into the clash when they don't
need to
that would be too much they're not
afraid of
the consequences of what they do or say
these are the people who write
you know ranting emails
really bad to send any sort of email
when you're upset right because
emails are forever whether you're
realizing it or not
now do people make in general
in your experience there are some people
who are courageous they are in the
middle
would you say in our society people
more often err on the side of
foolhardiness or more often
air on the side of cowardice in your
experience
what do you think
can you say this question well there's
some people that fall in the middle
that are actually courageous and then
there's these two advices
full heartiness and cowardice in our
society
where do you think more people who
aren't courageous fallen do you think
they're more
attending towards cowardice giving in on
things
or towards foolhardiness yeah
right now at this stage last year
sorry i think i see a lot more cool
parting spend okay but that's probably
going to change
that's interesting when do you when do
you think it'll change
i don't know just what i'm not
surrounded by college
polish people yeah in a way the risks
are
lower when you're a college student when
you've actually got you know
house spouse career kids
mortgage all that sort of stuff it might
be a little harder to stand up for
things
yeah yeah i was gonna say cowardice is
more common because i feel like a lot of
people are afraid to stand up for others
and hear what happens to them
yeah i saw this show what would you do
that's pretty popular and they're kind
of like
getting bullied or like weird situations
like someone yelling at someone and only
like a few people walk by like a hundred
say anything
yeah um that's a good point
and it would be you'd have to observe
those people who say something
in multiple cases to see whether they
fall sometimes
it's both or like one or the other i
mean some are really over the top really
angry and suddenly handle it really
responsibly so there's a mix in there
but
the majority of people just end up
walking back yeah
um somebody had their hand up over here
in the sort of
atmosphere all right
um i feel like uh like what alyssa said
like there's
like we tend to to think of the people
that use it in excess a lot because like
that's like they stand out
yeah that's the impression that we get
but i feel like for every person that
uses
their courage and access there's a lot
more people that are
deficient in it yeah cause that doesn't
stand because like that show you see the
one or two people
like as you see that one person that's
using it in excess there's three or four
people walking behind them
yeah and so now aristotle says another
thing about this tip
he says if you find yourself having a
vice
and you want to change that then or if
you're not sure where you fall in
and say one of them is further away from
the virtue you probably it's okay to
overshoot a little bit
so when you're teaching let's say we
think about assertiveness training
assertiveness training is one way
in our society that we use to try to
inculcate a little bit of courage into
people isn't it
we say no you don't have to act this way
you don't have to like punch them
or you know use abusive language but you
can tell them
how you feel is we lay down certain
limits
but if somebody's going to do that if
they're struggling with cowardice maybe
it's okay if they
overshoot a little bit so they can come
back this way because it's harder to
go this way this is further away
the other thing that he says is really
important is
the person who's in the middle they're
the standard
and the person who's virtuous
they're a model they behave the way
that's a just person or a courageous
person or a tempered person behaves
you can behave the same way as them
without necessarily having that
habit established without having the
virtue that's a good thing to do
but it doesn't mean that you actually
have that habit and how can you tell if
somebody
does or doesn't have that habit you look
at whether they
actually enjoy doing it so
for example like myself i'm not just
all the time i don't have to actually be
just all the time to have the virtue but
i'd have to be just
most of the time not only would i have
to be just most of the time
i would have to be just for the right
reasons because i
actually enjoy doing that sort of thing
so there'll be cases where i
you know you can be just with your your
time or attention or stuff like that
i'm not always happy about that even
when i do the right thing
i'm not always doing it because i
really love it i recognize it as the
right thing
i wish i could get away with not doing
it sometimes and so i'm not actually
virtuous in that respect
the virtuous person is the standard but
that doesn't mean that every action
that's in accordance with virtue
is already virtue is this that for
injustice i'm willing to bet that every
single one of you
has taken more than your fair share at
one time or another
yeah anybody who hasn't
probably not right did you feel bad when
you did it
not at all i mean i think eddie ben
where are like one talk about pick
anything
anything you like if you recognize it as
more than your fair share
um so you did something that you at that
time knew was wrong
did you feel bad about it did you think
there was a wrong thing to do
i mean sometimes that this is i mean
sometimes
let's say my mother used to bring some
cookies on yeah there you go that's
really important
if i had like five cookies i'm just
thinking
so that's mildly unjust yeah
sort of breaking it down the middle or
something right um
i mean it's a trivial instance my point
is this
if if you actually recognize if you do
the wrong thing
but you recognize the wrongness of it
aristotle would say you're not yet
vicious the vicious person actually
becomes blind in this over time
and comes to see the vice as the normal
thing and then
tends to push the virtue off on to the
other side
or tends to sort of annex the virtue to
their device so they'll
they'll say everybody's out for
themselves you've got to take as much as
you can get that's the right thing to do
that allows you to see egoism as
in some ways an expression of vice right
or the angry person who gets far too too
angry
they either see themselves as being
virtuous
i'm angry to the right amount or they
they say everybody else is including the
virtuous person
they're not angry enough they're not
behaving the way they should
the rash person sees the courageous
person as being a coward because they
back down sometimes
the coward the coward
the person who's got that in their soul
tends to see the courageous person as
being
and they see themselves as being prudent
there's other virtues and vices that are
that are particularly important
we're going to look at these more
specifically when we go to books
three three four and but i wanted to
mention them very quickly here
talking about emotions and actions right
what are actions concerned with when
aerosol says actions that could be a
little bit misleading
that works for courage for temperance
for justice
but you have to think about what are the
objects of your actions
what kind of actions are you engaged in
so think about something
that we care quite a bit about money
right
and now think about your personal
relations with with other people
is everybody totally on their own as far
as money when you're thinking about
family and friends
or do you sometimes spend money on other
people
or give them things or do they give you
things
it's the the other right so
can you give too much to people
or should you always just give more and
more and more and more
yeah i think once you give too much to
people they expect that from you so then
that's a problem yeah next time like you
do it and
you don't give them that as much they
take you for granted or
even if you give them a lot they'll
sometimes still take you for granted for
it
that is one problem with what aristotle
calls prodigality which is giving giving
too much
of goods for property in relations
um what about the other extreme are
there people who just want to take and
not give
yeah um the right amount is to
give in sort of some reciprocal way but
to be more concerned with giving than
taking right
those are the kind of people you'd want
to have as friends the generous
aristotle uses this word liberality
which which
we don't use that much in our society so
i think generous probably works better
for that and think about all the
different ways in which you can be
generous just in a
level as a college student do you ever
go out to eat with your friends
who picks up the tap everyone split it
you know perfectly equally or
you ever pick up the tab and they get it
the next time
never depends how many people you went
out with
yeah i suppose if you're doing a big
table
yeah that's a that's an interesting one
we didn't have that in our time i wish
we did
yeah you know you can think about this
buying buying rounds or drinks you can
think about this
with giving gifts to people you can
think about this with
exchanging favors you can think about
this with going to visit somebody's
house you know you will have
relationships the rest of your life
where
how you use wealth in relation to other
people
is really key and you can have the mean
in between you can have the extreme of
giving too much and then often
winding up not having enough to get and
having to see the elsewhere
and you can have the extreme of
not giving being stingy being a tight
one
being ungenerous you can do this on a
larger scale too arizona points out
think about these buildings on campus
they all have names right lafontaine
you know fontaine i'm sorry yeah there's
an author
who's this fontaine person i don't know
do any of you know
there's a plaque out front he was a
brother okay
in this case then it was named after
somebody who didn't donate themselves
right usually these things are whoever
donated well like the hancock
building or like the dyson building
they're usually like the people that put
the most money into that yeah now
aristotle thought that people who have
wealth within a society have a
responsibility to contribute to the
to the well functioning of the society
one way that they do that is by making
by spending their their well and you can
do that to the
right of the right amount you can also
do that
uh too little some some wealthy people
screw everyone else
you know they're gonna leave them all to
their hands
can you go too far with that what do you
think
how how might you go too far
i got to go too many ways how would you
say you could go through the park
spending on public things of your own
resources yeah
i mean just in terms of like everyday
behavior if you over give
to your friends and you expect that in
return you don't
get it back and that's just going to
disappoint okay you've actually managed
to combine both of the aspects
the rich person could like bankrupt
themselves in getting didn't they
they could also give it for the wrong
reason expecting
too much uh aristotle calls this
vulgarity
you know or sort of empty display there
are some people who
buy they do massive things buying people
things so they want everyone to like
them
to think they're a big big shot you know
an important person
aristotle would see that as a vice and
so that would be
on a larger public scale and you can
think about this with ambition
you can think about this with social
relations
uh it looks like i'm keeping you over a
little bit of time so i'm gonna
break off here sorry about that and have
a good weekend